- [Interviewer] All right.
Anaya, Anaya, where'd you grow up?
Where you from, originally?
- I'm from Centinela hospital.
Centinela hospital-
- [Interviewer] So what
city did you grow up?
- LA.
Los Angeles.
- [Interviewer] Inglewood?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Lemme start over,
just say Inglewood cause otherwise..
- Yeah, Inglewood. LA to be exact.
Inglewood is in LA so..
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
lemme start, just say Inglewood
when I ask you where I'm from.
- Yeah, I'm from..
- [Interviewer] Here, I'll ask you first.
- I mean, I was born in Inglewood,
but like, I've never grew
up in this neighborhood.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you grow up?
- Well, me and my mom,
we moved to Victorville
when I was like 10.
Because of the violence.
Like, our house got shot
up when I was a kid.
- [Interviewer] Oh, Inglewood is..
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So Victorville's safer.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- My childhood was, I seen a
lot of things that I wasn't
supposed to see.
Like, you know, my mom
bringing in dudes in the house,
and you know..
you know, just her getting
drunk and everything like that.
You know, my mom, she's an alcoholic,
so she just always used
to like bring dudes in,
and I try to go to sleep when I was a kid,
but she'd always have like
music playing and blasting.
And I tried to go to sleep,
but I couldn't sleep,
because I knew my mom was
doing something wrong.
That she wasn't supposed to be doing.
And I just wanted to be with my dad,
because my dad always was there for me.
And my dad is not a deadbeat.
He's always, he's a good.. My dad is good.
And my dad loves me so much.
And my dad loves me more than my mom.
And that's why I lived with
my dad half of my life.
But,
me and my mom we fought,
I fought my mom and you know,
I know that's a sin, but I fought my mom.
Like we act like I actually socked her
in her face and all that.
But,
me and mom we don't get along
because she's an alcoholic,
and she's jealous of me, her own daughter.
So, you know.
- [Interviewer] Do you have siblings?
- Yeah. I have six
brothers and two sisters.
We all have different dads.
Same mom.
- [Interviewer] And your dad
was kind of in your life or?
- My dad was always in my life.
- [Interviewer] He was.
- Yeah, he's always there for me.
He's always there.
- [Interviewer] So there were
drugs in the house as well,
or just alcohol?
- No, not in my dad's house. Just alcohol.
My dad. Yeah, he just..
- [Interviewer] But in your mom's?
- No, just alcohol.
She'd hook up with other guys,
and they get her high, pills
and ecstasy and all that.
She'd be so drunk. Like she
has one boyfriend that's,
one guy that's there for her,
that is always helping her out.
She gets so drunk to the
point where she fall out
and I see that, you know, I seen it,
and it's not nice to see
being her kid, you know.
Who wants to see their
mom, like, you know,
drunk and falling over drunk.
Like, you know?
So drunk to the point
where she hits her head,
and I don't know, she's
just, you know, alcoholic.
So,
I try to be there for her.
She says that she loves me,
and I try to be there with her but,
my mom was crazy.
So,
that's why she tries to
keep my daughter from me,
because I'm not in my right state of mind.
But..
I wanna change the subject.
- [Interviewer] Chuckles. It's okay.
So what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- What kind of what?
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- I was a good kid.
I didn't understand Math.
I always failed Math.
Like I try to go up to the board and like,
because the teacher called
on me to solve a problem,
and I try to go up to the board and..
Well in the suburbs,
when I went to a RSM
Intermediate High School,
Intermediate Middle School,
and they called me up to the board,
and
I was embarrassed because I
couldn't solve a problem that..
algebra problem, I couldn't solve it.
I couldn't solve the problem.
And I felt singled out
because it was all white people, you know?
And..
One kid walked up after me,
before I left the white board,
I went back to my seat and he walked up.
He solved the problem
and everybody laughed.
And that's something that I won't forget.
I still don't,(coughs)
I still don't understand it, you know?
I'm good in History, you know,
I can do History, English
and all that but...
- [Interviewer] So you
left home at what age?
- 16.
- [Interviewer] 16. Did
you finish high school?
- I dropped off.
I dropped out when I was in 11th grade.
- [Interviewer] And where'd you go?
- To the streets.
I was 16 when I got this
tattoo here, my first tattoo,
"Beauty is Pain."
And then I dropped out,
because I think my mom lost her house.
So, I was living with my mom at the time
and she lost the house.
So, I dropped out.
And I..
I don't have a high school diploma,
but I went to..I was in Orange County,
and I went to this continuation school
called Access in Orange County,
and
my credits were building up,
but I dropped out of that too.
I almost made it, but I mean,
I think I can still go
to adult school, but
you know,
I don't have a diploma or anything,
but I can still try to go and you know,
make something out of myself.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- 23.
- [Interviewer] 23. So
where do you live now?
- I'm homeless currently.
Currently I'm homeless right now.
- [Interviewer] Living on skid row?
- Skid row? No. No.
- [Interviewer] You came down
here today for something,
but you live where?
- All my life, I lived-
- [Interviewer] Like when you're homeless,
where do you stay at night?
- I sleep wherever like,
you know, I sleep in cars.
I sleep in cars,
I sleep in motels,
I sleep in the bus stop,
I sleep wherever, you know, wherever-
- [Interviewer] Just wing it.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are you
using any of the drugs
that are on the street?
- Well, I've been doing meth for about,
I'll say now for about six years.
I've never shot it, but I
smoke it and I started off.
I started.. I first started
using.. I started snorting it.
Then I started smoking it.
I never shot it, but I've done a hot rail,
but I don't really want
to do a hot rail anymore
because that gives me way
out of my mind, you know,
takes me somewhere where
I don't want to be.
- [Interviewer] And how do
you support yourself now?
- I don't.
- [Interviewer] To buy food or clothes or,
or meth or whatever costs money?
- People help me out, you know?
Cause I'm just like everybody
else because I'm homeless now.
So I'm just like everybody else, you know?
So, I might get blessed
for like a few dollars or,
you know, a water bottle or
you know, food or, you know,
a cigarette, whatever it is.
- [Interviewer] So a lot
of the girls on the street
are dating guys for
money. You don't do that?
- I have, yeah, I've done
it, but I've done it.
But like when I was 16,
when I left my mom's house,
and I went with my friend Beauty,
I tried, I ran behind her.
I wasn't being a leader,
I was being a follower.
So, I thought I wanted
to follow her and lead,
and you know, do what she did,
but that wasn't really my motto.
That was just something
that I was trying to do to,
I guess fit in and be, you
know, grown at the time.
But I wasn't. You know, just, you know,
I was just a little girl just
moving too fast, you know?
- [Interviewer] And do you have a child?
- Yeah, she's two.
Her name is Abella.
Abella Eileen Sanders.
- [Interviewer] And she's with your mom?
- She's with my mom. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How often do you see her?
- I see her..I don't see her.
I was supposed to see her on my birthday,
but never called my mom.
I was too stuck up in
my own ways, you know,
because of my, it was my birthday.
So I was just thinking
about myself, you know,
at the time.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think about your life
may have led you down this path?
Was it your relationship-
- My relationship.
- Your relationship with your mom?
- I think that is what it is.
It's also that, and you know,
when my grandma passed away,
she told me that I was
gonna get what I deserve
for disrespecting her.
And she did everything
just to make me happy when
I was little.
She did everything she could.
She bought me clothes,
McDonald's all the time.
You know, she was there
for me all the time.
Picked me up from school, all the time.
When my dad didn't.
She was always there for me.
But I disrespected her when I was...
I disrespected her when I was younger.
- [Interviewer] So this life.
Living on the street, no responsibility,
no bills, no nothing.
Is something you enjoy do you think or?
- No, I don't like it.
No, I want bills.
I mean, no, I don't want
bills, but I want, you know,
I want an apartment and
everything like that, you know.
I want somewhere to stay, you know.
I don't wanna be homeless,
like it's not for me.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think stops you from getting
your life together?
- Honestly, me, if I
don't try hard enough.
If I don't put it in the
credits, and the effort to try
to survive and thrive like stronger,
and just be like, independent,
and just do everything that I have to do.
Like, it's not really hard.
I just have to try.
But I mean, I can do it on my own,
but then again it's like,
everybody needs help. You know?
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your 23 years?
- Treat people how you want to be treated.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- I don't.
I don't really consider people
my friends who I just meet,
come up to me asking me for favors.
You know, they're not really my friends.
They're just people in need. You know?
- [Interviewer] Where are your siblings?
- I actually, I don't know
they are, you know my...
They moved out of my mom's house.
We're all grown up now.
Like, you know, my brother's in Colton,
my youngest brother's in Colton,
my other brother's in Victorville.
My other brother stays out here in LA.
My other brother stays in Orange County,
and then my other brother's adopted.
I don't know where he is, but you know.
You know it is what it is.
You can't change anything
that's meant to stay the same.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like you get in your own way
sometimes, and you've put
yourself in this situation,
or do you blame your
childhood with your mom
or something like that?
- I blame it on my mom.
My grandma was my real mom, honestly.
You know, my mom, she you know what?
I do love my mom, but it's like,
I have regrets because of what she's done.
All the things that I've seen,
in the way that she treated me.
Like, she called me
(expletive) and (expletive),
and all that.
Like, when I was like, like 10 years old.
Like 10 up until like 16 to 23.
Like it just won't change.
Like, you know,
I don't know what I can
do to make her happy,
but, you know, cause her homegirls,
ever since she started hanging
out with this, her homegirl,
because her homegirl calls
her kids (expletive).
And so ever since she
started hanging around her,
she started, you know,
picking up her slang and all that.
So..
- [Interviewer] Do you think
that affects the way you,
maybe subconsciously believe
what you deserve, in life?
Like maybe you don't deserve a better life
if your own mother is-
- Oh yeah, I do deserve a
better life, but it's like,
I'm just so stuck in the.. I
think it's because of my age.
I think that's what it is.
I'm not ready to let go yet.
But I think like once I
get older a little bit,
or once I get my (expletive)
together, I'll, you know,
I'll let go of it.
I'll let it go.
But right now it's just
like, it hurts really bad.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most frustrating thing
you deal with-
- The most fresh frustrating thing is,
see I'm grown now and it's like,
because when I was younger,
like when I was 18 to like 10 to 18 to 17,
I was with my mom and dad.
Now it's like, because I'm
older, they're not there anymore.
You know, that's the
most frustrating thing.
- [Interviewer] What about your child?
- That's frustrating too,
cause I'm not there for her either.
- [Interviewer] And where
do you see your life going
from here?
You're still young, so
you have a lot of time to-
- Honestly, I see myself...
I know that I'm gonna make it.
If I try hard enough, I
know that I'll make it.
But it's not that easy, you know.
There's always something
in the way, you know.
You can't trust anything.
I can't trust myself.
As long as I love myself,
and love God,
and try to be better than I was yesterday,
then I can do it.
That's all I have to say.
- [Interviewer] All right fine.
Thank you so much for talking with me.